our job
is to taste free air
your so-called boss mate on the clock
that taunts you from the wall but my
friends the hour is yours
hey guys pete here today i'm talking
about severance episode 8 which was the
penultimate episode of this amazing
first season and to me what's for dinner
felt more like a part one of two because
it ended on this big cliffhanger the
show has given us a ton to speculate on
it's been a great ride and we are hoping
that we'll get some answers in the
finale but where this was left i think
we need to temper our expectations we're
gonna need a season two a lot did happen
here though and i'll be recapping all of
it i'll come back around and tell you
what i think it means and look at some
theories right after this quick spoiler
warning if you haven't watched severance
season 1 episode 8 yet then this video
won't be for you and with that out of
the way let's get into it the episode
opens with irv's audi he has a dog he
kind of looks like an artist and he
drinks coffee at night in his normal
looking apartment where he has a room
where it looks like he paints the same
painting over and over again while
listening to the ace of spades by
motorhead he uses thick black paint to
bring to life what at this point looks
like the hallway to the break room it's
not and we will come back to what it
actually is but he's obsessed with it
and we do get some idea of why he's
falling asleep on the job and where this
black goo imagery that he keeps seeing
comes from plus the black that we saw
under his fingernails it's pretty
exciting we're getting some payoff there
and also the hint that there's obviously
some crossover between his innie and
audi and that he's painting something
from the severed floor there we find out
a couple of days have passed they're at
the end of the quarter everyone's in the
office but only helly's at her
workstation because it's down to her to
be able to finish on time so that they
can make their quota she does eventually
do that she's rewarded with an animation
of keir himself that's almost like a
video game end screen and everyone's in
high spirits and when irving says so
it's on now we can see that they're
ready to move forward with their plan
mark goes in to see harmony she's in a
great mood there's some talk about who's
gonna get the waffle party and he
suggests dylan because of their plan and
she tells him to go to wellness for an
end of the quarter session when he gets
there he finds out that lumen has hired
a new wellness director and that ms
casey will be retiring at the end of
this session she just found this out he
feels responsible but she still tries to
go ahead and give him a session telling
him nice things about his audi he
interrupts her and says he's gonna try
to talk to someone and she tells him
that she really liked being in the
office with everyone in his department
that day she knows she's strange she
says that her life has only been 107
hours long and most of that has been in
these half hour sessions which i guess
explains the idea of a part-time innie
she goes further to say that for her her
favorite time was that day that she
spent in their department watching helly
it was the longest that she's ever been
awake cobell is watching all of this and
mark thinks there must be something they
can do and when she asks why he cares
what happens to her he says because
we're people not parts of people no one
can just turn you off she tells him that
he's nice and harmony sighs audibly in
front of her screen when that happens
and we notice that milchex there and he
says you know what's good right that
they don't remember each other it means
the chips work it's a win and this
doesn't do much to explain why it is
that she looks like his wife gemma in
response to that kobold tells him to
take her back down to the testing floor
and it's hard to get a read on what's
going on with her in this moment she
looks pain she says it slowly and it all
leaves us with a lot to speculate about
we do see milchak escort her to a
doorway it's got a long hallway inside
and as she starts walking down it she
turns to him and asks him if he knows if
she's happy up there she's asking about
her audi he gives her a pat answer he
says of course you do you do lots of
wonderful things and when she turns to
continue you can see that she has a tear
in her eye she tries to turn again and
looks like she wants to say more but he
cuts her off saying that he's sorry he
just has so much to do today at the end
of the hallway she enters what is
basically a secret elevator and when the
doors close you see that this is
actually what irv keeps painting not the
break room hall so just an amazing
amount of wtf right here and i'll have
to come back to it because there's still
a lot to get through in this recap
as mark is asking everyone if they're
still sure they want to go through with
the plan milcheck comes in and asks if
any macro dats are ready to party dylan
will get his waffle party at the end of
the day and the rest of them get to
enjoy the pre-waffle party egg bar
social and dylan gets an additional
prize which isn't revealed until later
things take a turn for harmony when she
finds natalie in her office holding
pictures of helly's suicide attempt she
admits that it happened and asked if
milchek gave her the photos natalie also
mentions that they know she's been
spending time at the house of mark's
sister and then she tells her she needs
to be suspended from her position
immediately and that she's fired from
what we know about cobell this is
essentially the end of the world she
looks horrified she asks if the board is
even there and then you hear someone
answer yes in a quiet voice that comes
from the speaker she tries to go over
and compose herself saying that she can
explain everything to the board tonight
and natalie just says the board has
concluded the call
milcheck gets pulled away from the party
to walk her out he takes her security
card and she just sort of walks out the
door to the stairwell without saying
anything you do see that she has a
meltdown in the car on the way home and
when she gets there she starts trashing
the place including her shrine room she
destroys the shrine itself and then
falls to the floor holding the blue tube
that the charlotte cobell bracelet was
sitting on you see the innies go over
their plan before they get ready to
leave after the waffle party dylan will
take the card and go into the security
office the plan for when it goes down is
for each of them to go to someone that
they think they can trust and tell them
everything they don't know how long
they're gonna have so they have to be
ready for anything mark pulls out
rickon's book thinking he's the only one
who read it but as he reads the passage
dylan joins in and helps him finish it
saying that page 197 slaps at the end
irv goes up first and as hallie's
getting ready to go she comes back out
of the elevator to give mark a kiss just
in case they don't come back or she says
i don't know in case we do and they were
building up this chemistry with them
over the last couple of episodes there
was a scene earlier where they were
staring into each other's eyes almost
lovingly and this could make things
interesting if miss casey comes back
into the picture on mark's way out you
see that they're changing the sign out
front to say welcome friends of bloomin
and this all seems like it's related to
the eagan family gala dylan is escorted
to the perpetuity wing and you learn
that the waffle party takes place in the
replica of keir's house that they have
there it starts out fairly normal
there's a plate of waffles a glass of
milk he puts some syrup on them and he
starts to eat as he's finishing you see
there are instructions printed on the
plate it says go now to the founder's
bed there he finds a cure mask that he
puts on and on the bed there is a cat of
nine tails whip with the nine core
principles printed on each of its thongs
music starts playing and we get some
dancers and there's this crazy
juxtaposition of them wearing sexy
costumes with giant creepy masks now
it's hard to say what exactly is going
on here but this is clearly a reference
to the painting that we saw outside of
the wellness center except with the
notable edition of lingerie it's really
a shame that dylan's the one who's there
because he's already seen this i would
love to see a first-time visitor
experience this because i'm sure it
would be a lot like how my reaction was
to it what the hell is going on here
dylan is just indifferent and then as
they're finishing up they notice he's
already left and we see him walking away
carrying his box he's got stuff to do
on the outside we see mark knock on
cobell's door he's headed to devon and
rickon's party and she asked him to come
over and double check if mrs selvig was
interested in coming she would have been
busy at the gala but now she turns out
to be free and after turning him down
initially she changes her mind deciding
to drive herself mark arrives first and
he's greeted by rickon and it dawns on
you how awesome it might be if his any
wakes up here in front of his hero he
tells devin that they need to talk
because he's thinking of a fairly major
life change mrs selvik does arrive she
apologizes to mark saying that she had a
bad day at work and we see irv's audi
come home to his dog he gets a cup of
coffee and he starts a new painting
dylan makes it inside the office he uses
his belt to secure the door we see that
his prize was a 3d block like the one
that mark has on his desk his image is
the group photo of mdr so he looks at
that and effectively everyone else
before he starts to activate the
sequence he gets everything together and
then he struggles to reach both of the
override switches at the same time back
outside we see harmony ask mark about
this life change that she overheard him
mentioned to devin he tells her that
he's thinking about quitting lumen
saying that he doesn't know if he needs
severance anymore she hugs him and it
seems like she's excited about this and
she says that he should do it she says
get away from them mark and her look
changes to where she looks like she's
hurt but not by him by her experience of
being involved with lumen so right
before dylan hits the switch you see
that mark is still in an embrace with
her irv is painting by himself and then
you see helly's audi for the first time
she has her hair up she has a nice pair
of earrings on and it looks like she's
wearing a dress she's drinking a glass
of champagne and she almost has to be at
the egan family gala the episode ends as
dylan finally reaches the second switch
and we're gonna have to wait till next
week to see what happens
so wow a lot of stuff is going down as i
mentioned at the beginning stopping here
makes it seem like we'll see what
happens when they wake up and then maybe
some aftermath in the season finale it's
hard to say if that's going to get us
closer to knowing for sure what's
happening with ragabi or miss casey or
what they do at work or the baby goats
and so on
we're right in the middle of a big event
and i've read that the finale is only 41
minutes long i don't necessarily see
that as a problem if they did answer the
majority of those and the other
questions that are floating around it's
pretty hard to imagine how they might
continue beyond that they're just gonna
have to have a second season or possibly
multiple seasons and i'm here for that
it seems like the one major question
we'll absolutely get an answer to is
what is the deal with helly's audi the
brief glimpse that we get of her here
does make her look important and if she
is at the gala then she might even be
part of the family this has been a
popular theory which i think they did a
pretty good job of setting up while also
adding some things along the way to make
you doubt it seeing her in this evening
attire makes me lean way more to it
being true but it's also possible that
she's just someone that has influence or
is connected to them in some other way
things i'm less sure that we'll get
clarification on are ragabi and gemma
mark did take the card he seemed
interested in reintegration so she might
reach out to him but he also told his
sister in this episode that he was
thinking of quitting plus grainer is
gone and harmony is on the outs with
lumen and that makes it hard to see how
it might play into the finale the gemma
ms casey situation feels somewhat next
level and we're still not sure what
lumen is trying to accomplish through
the severance program miss casey as the
wellness director has been retired for
any of the regular innies that would be
the same as dying as we saw with bert
last week she also doesn't appear to
have an audi or at least not in the same
way that the full-timers do so it's
possible that they just keep repurposing
her for different roles does that mean
she's a robot or that gemma was brain
dead and they harvested her body from
the hospital i don't think that we have
enough information to tell and then
probably the most interesting new
question from me was why was audi irving
painting the elevator that we saw her
enter as an audi he shouldn't have any
memories related to the severed floor
and as any really shouldn't know about
the test floor in the previous episode
we got an indication that the chips can
possibly do more than just separate
their indian audi memories when heli was
flipping through the manual there were
other functions listed beyond just being
able to wake them up outside this week
as dylan was looking for the overtime
function we saw those names again things
like clean slate which sounds like they
might be able to reset their memories
and freeze frame and lullaby which makes
it sound like they might be able to take
control of them in different ways so it
feels like we just scratched the surface
as to what's really going on in the
basement and below harmony getting
canned ahead of her big face to face
with the board wasn't something i was
expecting this could be big considering
she obviously knows a lot about the
company and the eagan family could she
become an ally for her old employees i
mean she was certainly encouraging mark
to get away from lumen at the same time
she's the type of character that it's
hard to imagine her being anything other
than who she is but things are looking
to be pretty well turned upside down
also it sounded like milcheck sent the
pictures to natalie so he might just
step into her role i guess a lot will
depend on what happens with her whenever
mark wakes up in her arms if that
happens so we'll just have to wait and
see the shot with her holding on to the
breathing tube which i presume was her
mother's and all of the strange behavior
related to mark and miss casey certainly
point to her having her own agenda does
this go hand in hand with her being a
true believer or is it at odds with her
devotion to care the sensible wild
speculation seems to be that she's
trying to bring her mother back in the
same way that gemma came back but who
knows how that happened so just to run
back through things before i wrap it up
i guess the big question with dylan is
if he's going to get caught there hasn't
been anyone in the office since greener
died but there is at least a hint that
two people were there when they woke him
up at home while they will need a
replacement for grainer next season i'm
not sure if they'll introduce a brand
new character in the finale with irv it
was nice to see where the black goo the
dirty fingernails and dozing at work was
coming from also his dog being named
radar was a nice payoff to his first
wellness session where she told him that
his audi likes the sound of radar he
appears to be a loner so not sure what
to expect when he wakes up but there was
a shot of him in a car in one of the
teasers that hasn't been shown yet i
thought that there would be another
interaction with bert considering how
abrupt their goodbye was but i'm not
sure how that might happen at this point
people have guessed that burp might be a
permanent innie before he was retired
and i suppose now that we know about the
test floor he might be i just don't know
if there's enough time for him to see
the paintings or something like that on
the outside and then that setting off a
chain of events where he goes back to
work and something could happen before
the end of the season either way there
is a lot that's not adding up with his
character which leads me to believe that
there's more going on he might have been
retired before and then came back
there's an indication that he's been at
lumen for nine years but only in mdr for
three that could just mean that he was
unsevered before but it could also mean
that they performed the clean slate or
one of those other functions and now his
current inni is unaware of his past mark
waking up at rickens with koble right
there has a lot of potential i'm most
interested in him discovering that miss
casey is gemma but i don't even think
that has to happen in the next episode
considering the setup although when he
was talking to helly he said he just
hopes his audi has things he cares about
and that pretty much is it that's really
the only thing he cares about so it's
possible he could find out about her the
board is real at least somebody
responded to harmony so i hope we get
something about them with heli being at
the gala and there's just a ton of other
stuff and i think i'll probably do an
extra video this week so i think this is
a good place to leave this one let me
know in the comments what you thought
about this episode how it changed your
ideas about where this is headed which
answers would you most like to get in
the finale because i really don't think
we're gonna get them all and what are
you hoping to see in the next season
there's got to be a next season right
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already and thanks for watching
i'll talk to you soon